to do two things at once is to do
neither
it's a great smackdown of multitasking
isn't it often attributed to the roman
writer publius cirrus although you know
how these things are he probably never
said it
what i'm interested in though is is it
true i mean it's obviously true
for emailing at the dinner table or
texting while driving or possibly for
live tweeting a ted talk as well but i'd
like to argue that for an important kind
of activity
doing two things at once or three or
even four is exactly what we should be
aiming for
look no further than albert einstein
in 1905 he published four remarkable
scientific papers one of them was on
brownian motion it provided empirical
evidence that atoms exist and it laid
out the basic mathematics behind most of
financial economics another one was on
the theory of special relativity another
one was on the photoelectric effect
that's why solar panels work it's a nice
one
gave them the nobel prize for that one
and the fourth introduced an equation
you might have heard of e equals m c
squared
so tell me again how you shouldn't do
several things at once
now
obviously working simultaneously on
brownian motion special relativity and
the photoelectric effect it's not
exactly the same kind of multitasking as
snapchatting while you're watching
westworld
are very different
and einstein yeah well einstein's he's
einstein he's one of a kind he's unique
but the pattern of behavior that
einstein was demonstrating that's not
unique at all
it's very common among highly creative
people both artists and scientists and
i'd like to give it a name
slow motion multitasking
slow motion multitasking feels like a
counterintuitive idea what i'm
describing here is having multiple
projects on the go at the same time when
you move backwards and forwards between
topics as the mood takes you
or as the situation demands but the
reason it seems counterintuitive is
because we're used to lapsing into
multitasking out of desperation we're in
a hurry we want to do everything at once
if we were willing to slow multitasking
down
we might find that it works quite
brilliantly
sixty years ago
a young psychologist by the name of
bernice ageson began a long research
project into the personalities and the
working habits of 40 leading scientists
einstein was already dead but four of
her subjects won nobel prizes including
linus pauling and richard feynman
the research went on for decades in fact
it continued even after professor
agelson herself had died
and one of the questions that it
answered was how is it that some
scientists are able to go on producing
important work
right through their lives
what is it about these people is it
their personality is it their skill set
their daily routines oh
well the pattern that emerged was
clear and i think to some people
surprising
the top scientists kept changing the
subject they would shift topics
repeatedly during their first hundred
published research papers do you want to
guess how often
three times
five times
no on average the most enduringly
creative scientists switched topics
43 times in their first 100 research
papers
seems that the secret to creativity
is multitasking
in slow motion
ages research suggests we need to
reclaim multitasking and remind
ourselves how powerful it can be and
she's not the only person to have found
this different researchers using
different methods to study different
highly creative people have found that
very often they have multiple projects
in progress at the same time and they're
also far more likely than most of us to
have serious hobbies
slow motion multitasking among creative
people is ubiquitous
so why
i think there are three reasons and the
first is the simplest
creativity often comes when you take an
idea from its original context and you
move it somewhere else it's easier to
think outside the box if you spend your
time clambering from one box into
another
for an example of this consider the
original
eureka moment
archimedes he's wrestling with a
difficult problem and he realizes in a
flash
he can solve it
using the displacement of water
and if you believe the story this idea
comes to him as he's taking a bath
lowering himself in and he's watching
the water level rise and fall
and if
solving a problem while having a bath
isn't multitasking i don't know what is
the second reason that multitasking can
work is that learning to do one thing
well can often help you do something
else
i think any athlete can tell you about
the benefits of cross training it's
possible to cross train your mind too
a few years ago researchers took 18
randomly chosen medical students and
they enrolled them in a course at the
philadelphia museum of art where they
learned to criticize and analyze works
of visual art and at the end of the
course
these students were compared with a
control group of their fellow medical
students and the ones who had taken the
art course had become substantially
better at performing tasks such as
diagnosing diseases of the eye by
analyzing photographs that become better
eye doctors so if we want to become
better what we do
maybe we should spend some time doing
something else even if the two fields
appear to be as completely distinct as
ophthalmology and the history of art
and if you'd like an example of this
should we go for a less intimidating
example than einstein okay
michael crichton creator of jurassic
park and er
so in the 1970s he originally trained as
a doctor but then he wrote novels
uh and he directed the original
westworld movie but also and this is
less well-known he also wrote
non-fiction books about art about
medicine about computer programming
so in 1995 he enjoyed the fruits of all
this variety
by penning
the world's most commercially successful
book
and
the world's most commercially successful
tv series
and
the world's most commercially successful
movie
in 1996 he did it all over again
there's a third reason
why slow motion multitasking
can help us solve problems
it can provide assistance when we're
stuck
this can happen in an instant so imagine
that feeling of working on a crossword
puzzle and you can't figure out the
answer and the reason you can't is
because the wrong answer is stuck in
your head
it's very easy just go and do something
else
switch topics switch context you'll
forget the wrong answer and that gives
the right answer space to pop into the
front of your mind
but on the slower time scale that
interests me
being stuck is a much more serious thing
you you get turned down for funding
your cell cultures won't grow your
rockets keep crashing
nobody wants to publish your fantasy
novel about a school for wizards
or
maybe you just can't find a solution to
the problem that you're working on
and being stuck like that i mean stasis
stress
possibly even depression
but if you have another
exciting challenging project to work on
and being stuck on one it's just an
opportunity to do something else
we can all get stuck sometimes even
albert einstein ten years after the
original miraculous year that i
described einstein was putting together
the pieces of his theory of general
relativity his greatest achievement
and he was exhausted
and so he turned to an easier problem he
proposed the stimulated admission of
radiation
which as you may know is the zir
in laser
so he's
laying down the theoretical foundation
for the laser beam and then while he's
doing that he moves back to general
relativity and he's refreshed he sees
what the theory implies that the
universe isn't static
it's expanding
it's an idea so staggering einstein
can't bring himself to believe it for
years
look if you get stuck
and you lay the book you get the ball
rolling
on laser beams
you're in pretty good shape
so that's the case for slow motion
multitasking and i'm not promising that
it's going to turn you into einstein i'm
not even promising it's going to turn
you into michael crichton
but it is a powerful way to organize our
creative lives
but there's a problem
how do we stop all of these projects
becoming completely overwhelming
how do we keep all these ideas straight
in our minds
well here's a simple solution a
practical solution from the great
american choreographer twyla tharp over
the last few decades she's blurred
boundaries mixed genres won prizes
danced to the music of everybody from
philip glass to billy joel
she's written three books i mean she's a
she's a slow motion multitasker of
course she is
she says
you have to be all
things why exclude you have to be
everything
and tharp's
method for preventing all of these
different projects from becoming
overwhelming is a simple one she gives
each project a big cardboard box writes
the name of the project on the side of
the box and into it she tosses dvds and
books magazine cuttings theater programs
physical objects really anything
that's provided a source of creative
inspiration
and she writes
the box
means i never have to worry about
forgetting
one of the biggest fears for a creative
person is that some brilliant idea will
get lost because
you didn't write it down and put it in a
safe place
i don't worry about that
because i know where to find it
it's all in the box
you can manage many ideas like this
either in physical boxes
or in their digital equivalents
so i would like to urge you to embrace
the art of slow motion multitasking
not because you're in a hurry
but because you're in no hurry at all
and i want to give you one
final example my favorite example
charles darwin
a man whose slow slow-burning
multi-tasking is so staggering i need a
diagram to explain it all to you
we know what darwin was doing at
different times because the creativity
researchers howard gruber and sarah
davis have analyzed his diaries and his
notebooks
so when he left school age of 18 he was
initially interested in two fields so
zoology
and geology
pretty soon he signed up to be the
onboard naturalist on the beagle this is
the the ship that eventually took five
years to sail all the way around the
southern oceans of the earth stopping at
the galapagos passing through the indian
ocean while he was on the beagle he
began researching coral reefs this is a
great synergy between his two interests
in zoology and geology and it starts to
get him thinking about slow processes
but when he gets back from the voyage
his interests start to expand even
further psychology botany for the rest
of his life he's moving backwards and
forwards between these different fields
he never quite abandons any of them
in 1837 he begins work on two very
interesting projects one of them
earthworms
the other
a little notebook which he titles the
transmutation of species
then
darwin starts studying
economics
he reads a book by the economist thomas
malthus
and he has his eureka moment in a flash
he realizes how species could emerge and
evolve slowly through this process of
the survival of the fittest it all comes
to him he writes it all down
every single important element of the
theory of evolution in that notebook
but then
a new project
his son williams born
well
there's a natural experiment right there
you get to observe the development of a
human inference so immediately darwin
starts making notes now of course he's
still working on the theory of
revolution and
the development of the human infant
but during all of this
he realizes he doesn't really know
enough about taxonomy so he starts
studying that and in the end he spends
eight years becoming the world's leading
expert
on barnacles
then natural selection a book that he's
to continue working on for his entire
life he never finishes it
origin of species is finally published
20 years after darwin set out all the
basic elements
then the descent of man controversial
book and then
the book about the development of the
human infant the one that was inspired
when he could see his son william
crawling on the the city room floor in
front of him when the book was published
william was 37 years old
and all this time
darwin's working on earthworms
he fills his billiard room with
earthworms in pots with glass covers he
shines lights on them to see if they'll
respond he holds a hot poker next to
them to see if they move away he clears
tobacco and
he blows on the earthworms to see if
they have a sense of smell he even plays
the bassoon at the earthworms
i like to think of this great man
when he's tired
he's stressed he's anxious about the
reception of his book the descent of man
you or i
might log into facebook or turn on the
television
darwin would go into the billiard room
to relax by studying the earthworms
intensely
and that's why it's appropriate that one
of his last great works
is the formation of vegetable mold
through the action of worms
he worked upon that book
for 44 years
we don't live in the 19th century
anymore
i don't think
any of us could sit on our creative or
scientific projects
for 44 years
but we do have something to learn from
the great slow-motion multi-taskers from
einstein and darwin
to michael crichton and twyla twilotharp
the modern world seems to present us
with a choice
if we're not going to fast twitch from
browser window to browser window we have
to live like a hermit focus on one thing
to the exclusion of everything else
i think that's a false dilemma
we can make multitasking work for us
unleashing our natural creativity
we just need to slow it down
so
make a list of your projects
put down your phone
pick up a couple of cardboard boxes
and get to work
thank you very much
you